o iPhone wallpaper plena Ponte Estaiada
leite eu vou ver ele é
e acaba de nascer uma nova empresa a
cada minuto seis novas empresas nascem
no Brasil empreendedores cheios de
sonhos cheia de energia vontade de
construir vontade de realizar né de
conquistar aquela vida dos Milionários
lá das mídias sociais os empreendedores
milionários das mídias sociais que estão
tão perto da gente né ao alcance de um
clique eu quando comecei a empreender
imaginava que empreenderá ficar rico
então é montar um negócio ganhar
dinheiro e ficar rico Ninguém me falou
que antes de começar um negócio e ter
resultados expressivos teria uma jornada
tampa imagine Vamos lá comigo como eu
comecei imagine uma Belina 1979 eu sei
que a maioria de vocês nem sabe o que
que é uma Belina 1939 vai pesquisar no
Google mas é um carro velho carro antigo
tá então essa Belina ela não baixava os
vidros ela não tinha terceira marcha a
bateria Não segurava a carga os bancos
eles não tinham encosto era só no ferro
direto a gente não tinha estofamento a
gente encostava direto
Oi e essa esse carro por não segurar a
bateria eu tinha que ficar encostando em
pirambeira sempre para depois largar na
banguela engatar a marcha e já dá um
tranco ir para casa se eu não tivesse um
lugar assim para estacionar eu tinha que
empurrar ou seja empurrei muita beleza
muito muito muito mesmo e foi assim que
eu comecei então comigo no meu
pensamento de ser rico ser milionário
tendo um negócio eu comecei na verdade
com Abelino E aproveitando que a Gente
Tá imaginando a Belina lá sem poder
baixar os vírus Imaginem também uma
conta de 20 mil graus negativos foi
assim que a gente começou um carro velho
dívida sem experiência mas com muita
vontade de fazer acontecer com muita
vontade de aprender e construir a gente
na vida não faz nada sozinho enquanto a
maioria das pessoas Reza para o seu anjo
da guarda eu casei com meu né então eu
tô tendo o privilégio de trilhar toda
essa jornada da vida essa experiência
incrível ao lado do meu grande amor e do
meu anjo da guarda então quando a gente
eu sou mas quando eu comecei aqui a
empreender Montamos a empresa como é que
estou do Empreendedor comércio vendendo
né o empreendedor normalmente é o
primeiro vendedor da empresa aliás se o
empreendedor não for o primeiro vendedor
da empresa já começou errado é porque se
eu não consigo vender o meu produto como
que eu vou pedir para alguém fazer né
então preciso eu conseguir vender meu
produto meu serviço enfim eu comecei
assim também eu comecei batendo de porta
em porta não conhecia ninguém batia na
porta das pessoas sem imagine o susto de
quem abre a porta encontrava 1,88
vendendo batom porque eu comecei no ramo
da cosmética Eu vendi o batom perfume
maquiagem Campo Olha o susto no decorrer
desse momento eu tive muito aprendizado
foi Muito não Muito não Muito a porta
fechada mas também tive muitos sim
muitos outros anjos da guarda que for
aparecendo o nosso caminho ao longo do
nosso caminho que também foram abrindo
portas para gente Para que a gente
pudesse ir construindo pessoas que
acreditaram no nosso sonho só
o brilho no olho porque eu tinha dívida
e um carro velho e mesmo assim elas
acreditavam no nosso brilho no olhar na
nossa energia na nossa forma de
transmitir aquele sonho que a gente
tinha para realizar e vinham com a gente
e ajudaram a construir EA co criar tudo
isso foi sensacional esse momento aí um
determinado dia a gente recebeu uma
chamada para ir fazer um atendimento em
Jurerê Internacional eu moro em
Florianópolis né então Imagine você que
você tá no teu carro velho mas você
recebeu uma chamada de um cliente no
bairro mais obra da tua cidade e você
vai entrar no carro para ir aí você
entra no carro e vai e a gente tava
muito feliz que imagina não é uma
chamada do cliente novo no bairro mais
chique tíquete médio aumenta que legal
nosso trabalho tá chegando no local de
poder aquisitivo maior então o
empreendedor já começa a fazer plano né
e a gente no caminho indo quando eu faço
uma curva bate o olho
o pedágio bem grande escrito eu falei
meu Deus não tinha retorno não tinha
como parar eu tinha que passar por ali
só que com um detalhe eu não tinha nem o
réu eu tinha produtos para vender uma
marmita com arroz e feijão e o que era o
nosso almoço e só
bom e quando a gente estava chegando
perto minha esposa começou a chorar
olhei para o lado e ela tava chorando
ela fala meu Deus por que que a gente tá
passando por isso a gente tá fazendo
tudo certo porque que a gente vai ter
que passar vergonha dessa já não tenho
um real para pagar um pedágio
e na minha cabeça não é a perna bamba
descarga de adrenalina a mão trêmula
suando Eu já pensei que que eu vou
deixar né vou ter que deixar um
desodorante e um batom a marmita de
repente para poder passar porque eu
tinha que ir com outro lado trabalhar e
conforme eu fui chegando perto e nervoso
e tenso hein sabe quando forma foi
chegando perto eu vi que não tinha
cancela o posto tava desativado aí eu
passei por debaixo da estrutura aquela
descarga de adrenalina não conseguia nem
dirigir direito encostei o carro no
acostamento ali na frente
a perna bamba
e respirando fundo até agora ainda
emociona
eu olhei para o lado e tive o primeiro
grande compromisso firme o primeiro
grande compromisso empreendedor da minha
vida eu olhei para o lado para minha
esposa e eu fiz um compromisso de que eu
nunca mais ia ver a mulher que eu amo o
meu anjo da guarda passar por aquilo ela
abriu mão de vários sonhos na vida ela
abriu mão de vários projetos que ela
tinha para ela para estar comigo
construindo esse projeto então eu não
tinha o direito de deixar ela passar por
isso naquele momento eu passei a não
aceitar mais a derrota e aqui fica uma
grande lição empreendedora nunca aceite
a derrota Aprenda com a derrota mas não
aceita ela e também o aberto Alessandro
Papai do céu porque metros anos a gente
tinha falado por quê que nós estamos
passando por isso ele me deu a lição
falando cara faz o correto que eu abro
as portas para você não tinha cancela
e faz a coisa certa que eu abro as
portas para você porque a tua jornada é
de aprendizado Olha que reflexão
importante que a gente teve assim e eu
passei entender que a Belina que era o
carro que me fazer passar vergonha
também essa é a maior fonte de
aprendizado que eu ia ter foi a Belina
que me ensinou muita coisa foi através
dela que eu reencontrei a resiliência e
o poder que a resiliência tem na nossa
vida de nos impulsionar novamente a
grandes resultados eu aprendi naqueles
instantes nesse momento de vida que a
gente não mede sucesso eu medi o meu
sucesso pelo dos outros pelo Milionário
da mídia social não meu sucesso é meu
para algumas pessoas comprar uma
Mercedes não faz diferença nenhuma
porque quando eu fiz 18 anos papai me
deu um carro importado de presente para
outras pessoas comprar um Fusca uma
alegria muito grande porque na família
ninguém nunca teve um carro
e eu aprendi que para algumas pessoas
formar na faculdade ele é o centésimo da
família se formar para outras pessoas
chega a ser surreal se formar na
faculdade que ele é o primeiro da
família conseguir ter uma graduação
superior
e eu entendi que eu não posso pedir o
meu sucesso a minha grama pela grama do
vizinho eu vou botar o foco no que eu
controlo eu vou botar o foco no meu
projeto eu vou botar o foco naquilo que
faz sentido para mim e apesar de todos
esses ensinamentos ainda não era fácil a
gente chegou até luz cortada da empresa
com o cliente dentro do balcão atendendo
o cliente lotado e cortar a luz é dar
uma desculpa é Juntar uma grana sair
correndo lá na companhia elétrica pega
fila pede ligação de emergência aí atrás
a outras contas Porque essa já você
pagou o dinheiro que você pagar outras
contas tudo muito curto muito justo aí
antecipar recebível pagar juro aí paga
juro de novo pagar juros de novo paga
ajuda de novo pra se identificando como
empreendedor eu sei como você se sente
eu já me senti assim mas sabe coco foi a
grande sacada que a gente percebeu que
foi o segundo grande compromisso que eu
tive empreendedor e que fez muito
sentido para mim eu entendi que quanto
mais eu compartilhava o que eu conhecia
mas eu multiplicar arr
ah é verdade pode parecer um pouco
incoerente mas quanto mais eu divido
mais eu multiplico a gente começou a
dividir o que a gente sabia que a nossa
equipe a nossa equipe começou a trazer
resultado e começamos aumentar a equipe
de venda e aquilo começou a ficar
orgânico mas a gente entendeu que para
que esse crescimento fosse sustentável a
gente precisava se agigantar nós
precisávamos estudar mais nós precisamos
aprender mais então vamos para dentro de
cursos palestra Palestra Gratuita Não
perdia uma gente tava em todas todas as
parece da associação comercial CDL todas
a gente estava dentro para poder
aprender o tempo todo aprendendo até
hoje sempre que eu participo de uma
mentoria eu tô com meu caderno anotando
porque eu quero aprender eu tenho essa
obrigação comigo mesmo está aprendendo e
evoluindo né a gente buscava aqueles
curso sabe o comprei um vai dois então a
gente buscava esses né pagava por um e
dois podiam fazer o curso quando não
conseguia a gente pegava alguma promoção
de um curso que interessava um fazia e
em
bom e como isso fez bem para nós Sabe
quantas vezes ela me ensinando dentro do
carro eu dirigindo ela me ensinando o
curso que ela fez quantas vezes eu no
quarto ou na sala ensinando ela o curso
que eu fiz entendeu o quanto a gente
fortaleceu uma corrente aliás se a gente
tem o hábito de medir a força de uma
corrente pelo seu elo mais fraco
conforte a gente deixou esse Elo quando
a gente começa a fortalecer os elos mais
fracos essa corrente que potência ela
passa a ter EA gente começou a perceber
isso a gente começou a cada vez mais
atento a isso cada vez mais a entender
essência do Empreendedor entender que o
empreendedor ele ele ele é um eterno
incomodado ele nunca é acomodado e a
gente começou a desenvolver pessoas
envolver pessoas e começou a perceber
que essas pessoas se tornaram agentes de
transformação nas suas comunidades elas
passaram a ela serem o oxigênio daquela
sociedade então no lugar no lugar que
não tinha a vida
eu ouvi uma pessoa naquele local e essa
pessoa levava a vida levar o oxigênio
oxigênio vida e daí eu tive o terceiro
Insight terceiro compromisso que me veio
com forma muito clara de forma muito
clara e os líderes são oxigênio da
sociedade se a gente quer transformar se
a gente que ser um farol a gente
realmente quer que as pessoas se
inspirem eu preciso ser líder e
desenvolver líderes compartilhar aquilo
que eu sei que as pessoas Porque quanto
mais líderes eu desenvolver mas o
oxigênio a sociedade mas oportunidades
são geradas mais transformação acontece
e nesse momento a gente foi visitar os
nossos princípios a gente colocar a
precisamos dar uma olhada no nosso
princípio os princípios regem a nossa
vida eles estão presentes nos momentos
de decisão se você não sabe quais são os
seus princípios vai lá descobrir vai lá
estudava a identificar quais são a gente
tem os nossos a gente colocou mais um a
gente colocou que o bom é inimigo do
melhor então a gente não podia se conta
é bom a gente tinha que buscar você
sempre melhor e todo dia todo dia todo
dia na nossa vida a gente começou a ser
cada vez melhor a buscar que aprendizado
teve que eles são Aconteceu o quê que eu
aprendi com aquilo se eu ganhei um ótimo
quê que eu fiz que deu certo se eu perdi
não aceita essa derrota mas eu aprendo
com ela o que que eu posso fazer para
melhorar o que que eu posso fazer para
nunca mais passar por esse cenário a
gente compreendeu que o fundamental do
ser humano e entender o próximo
Oi e o ser humano é muito bom e julgar
nós somos muito bons em julgar os outros
EA maioria das pessoas pensa que quando
entende como outro pensa ele está
concordando com aquilo e não é verdade o
fato de eu entender como alguém pensa
não quer dizer que eu Concorde com ela
mas quando eu entendo como ela pensa o
porquê que ela tá tomando aquela decisão
a minha comunicação com ela é muito mais
assertiva existe respeita na nossa
relação Apesar de eu não concordar com
você eu te respeito eu entendo por que
que você tá fazendo isso e eu entendi o
meu grande propósito que é ser uma ponte
essa é uma ponte para conectar as
pessoas através da minha energia do meu
entusiasmo tá conectando pessoas
negócios para que todos prosperem para
que todos evolução é compartilhar o meu
conhecimento para que as pessoas possam
dar saltos de evolução na sua vida
e em fortalecer a corrente quanto tempo
vai levar para as pessoas entenderem que
a gente precisa fortalecer uma corrente
e se o elo mais fraco é o que mede eu
vou fortalecer o elo mais fraco também
eu não vou ficar só olhando para ela
mais forte ou pior só para o meu Elo não
eu vou fortalecer a corrente eu ouço
muita gente falar porque nesse momento
né que a gente vive uma economia que
muda o tempo todo na economia que tá
super dinâmica eu uso muito esse falar
Smart City e pouco de smart people
e a gente precisa evoluir as pessoas
hoje eu tenho privilégio de trabalhar
com grandes empreendedores trabalhar com
grandes empresas que vão The Big players
à microempreendedores pessoas
sensacionais que querem o que
desenvolver seus negócios o que faz
sentido para mim faz sentido conecta com
o meu propósito poder fazer as pessoas
acenderem o meu redor fazer as pessoas e
volume mas agora faz sentido para mim
Oi e esse é o são os desafios que eu
quero superar agora eu quero te fazer um
desafio eu quero que você pegue a pessoa
mais importante do mundo para você seu
pai sua mãe seus filhos sua esposa não
importa que esteja aqui que tenha
conexão com você você olha no olho dessa
pessoa e diga Muito obrigado por me
suportar porque eu sei que tem dia que
nós acordamos e a gente olha no espelho
e a gente não se suporta e essa pessoa
está ali para te atender ela tá ali para
te ajudar ela tá ali para te fazer você
cada vez melhor então fica aqui esse
desafio maravilhoso um fortalecer a
corrente Bora fortalecer essa corrente
Curta essa jornada mais do que nunca só
entenda que no meio desse caminho
empreendedor e dessa atenção que você
não procure se o cara mais rico do
cemitério que você possa inspirar outros
empreendedores que você possa fazer
outras pessoas evoluírem que você possa
ser farol que ilumina o caminho do
próximo porque se eu sair de uma Belina
1977 vinte mil réis de dívida para ter
quatro em
e isso é super influente com várias
pessoas
E você também pode
e lidere pelo exemplo para que lá na
frente você possa olhar para trás e ver
que tudo valeu a pena
bom porque acaba de nascer uma nova
empresa e os líderes são oxigênio da
sociedade